i'm real outgoing especially you know
when i do start drinking
it just it can get a little a little
muddy that was country singer morgan
wallin speaking to e.t
just last month now the 27 year old
singer has been suspended indefinitely
from his record label
and pulled from country radio after
being caught on video
using a racial slur and fellow country
stars are speaking out
in a statement to e.t wallen apologized
saying quote i'm embarrassed and sorry i
used an unacceptable and inappropriate
racial slur that i wish i could take
back
there are no excuses to use this type of
language ever
i want to sincerely apologize for using
the word i promise to do better
after the video footage surfaced on
tuesday of the tennessee native using
the n-word
outside his home after a night out
country radio stations and streaming
services like sirius xm and pandora
quickly began removing wallen from their
stations
a spokesperson for iheart media the
nation's largest radio chain
tells et quote we have made the decision
to remove his music and content from our
stations effective immediately
cmt country music television is also
pulling the plug
tweeting we do not tolerate or condone
words and actions that are in direct
opposition to our core values that
celebrate diversity
equity and inclusion the country music
association who named wallin their new
artist of the year in november 2020
is also removing any digital content of
wallen from their platforms
the record labels who signed wallen big
loud and republic records
suspended his recording contract
indefinitely
saying such behavior will not be
tolerated
this isn't the first time wallen has
been surrounded by controversy
last year he was arrested in nashville
for public intoxication
months later he made headlines again
when he was pulled from performing on
saturday night live
after violating the show's covet 19
protocols
by partying in a bar he apologized at
the time
noting that he had quote some growing up
to do
he was rebooked on snl eight weeks later
[Music]
in response to wallen's recent actions
country artists like mickey guyton have
taken to social media to call the singer
out
mickey tweeted asking how many passes
will you continue to give
adding no one deserves to be cancelled
but this is unacceptable
maren morris also tweeting in part we
all know it wasn't his first time using
that word
we keep them rich and protected at all
costs with no recourse
radio personality bobby bones a long
time supporter of wallins also speaking
out
there is no room for that word
there is no room for
a limited view on any race
or sex or so much so that i just
it just makes me feel like that listen i
like morgan wallin as a person
this i don't like one bit he's got a lot
of self-evaluation to do friends
a lot
you